I'm gonna do the same thing we're gonna
walk through this question and I'll stop
any time we need to put something down
and try to add some information on so
what we're writing P and Q are ends of
the diameter of a circle stop the
sentence doesn't in there but that's
enough information for me to start doing
something okay
so I need a circle actually I am I
literally am bleeding because it's much
easier to draw big circles than like
like like small circles because I'm
using the UM
I'm using my shoulder as a witch
just barely scrape the definition of
what is a circle there's a circle
I need a diameter a diameter right now
it's tricky sometimes to remember all of
the different words me you've got a lot
of terminology their diameter what's one
of the other kinds of words you see you
see radius what else circumference now
Lisa I think those are the main ones out
there now he's the way that I try to
remember which is which okay I think the
diameters the easiest one to remember
because you're very familiar with
another word which has dire you know um
in geometry diaphragms I personally but
I thinking about dang or dice he is a
parallelogram right every quadrilateral
has two diagonals but what does the day
where does the diagonal go okay here's
one of them okay I could draw in the
other one but you only need one to see a
diagonals of diagonal because it goes
all the way across the shape right it
doesn't like stop at one point he has to
go all the way across between the angles
right diamines
across okay so therefore a diameter
means all the way across the circle
right now it's important it's all the
way across because it is not Vista
it's not this distance you're like
that's a cross right but yeah it's a
core it's not all the way across just
like this
that's not diagonal that's just some
random line right so the diagonals all
the way across a diameter is all the way
across okay to make sure it's all the
way it has to pass through Center okay
that's a diameter the circumference is
also very easy to tell for the name
because they know the other word but it
almost has the word little circle in all
right
it means to like it's certainly got
around right so that's this whole
distance around here that's the
circumference and that lays the radius
which is what distance is the radius
from its it's hard for the diamond it's
from the center it's this distance and
they've told us that's ten centimeters
okay now I've drawn up everything that's
on the first sentence in the question P
and Q P and Q are ends of the diameter
of a circle with that radius so far so
good
a points razor random all the
circumference of the circle that's just
like the previous question isn't it so
somewhere on this circumference not here
or here has to be like somewhere on the
line they pick a point find the
probability uh-huh probably okay so
what's the factory going to be it'll be
just to do it in shorthand favorable
outcomes over sample space okay what's
hole outcomes if you like now I have my
task now is to work out what the
favorable outcomes are and I want the
sample spaces find the probability that
the points within 10 centimeters of
either P or Q or distance is being
measurable in the circumference okay
it's a long sentence and that's fine put
it all together one at a time
ten centimeters frumpy but measured
along the circumference so for instance
a point like this right that's not going
to be chosen right it's not going to
chose
a point like this could be chosen okay
when they measure to get there they're
going to measure along the curved
circumference all the way around
yeah so it's it's gonna be curved around
now how far can I go I'm allowed to go
I'm allowed to attend seniors on either
side right yeah that's right so there's
my there's one one of ten centimeters
I just wanted such roughly the same as
that okay and in fact this question here
is kind of like this question but taking
this interval then like wrapping it
around a circle right it's that question
but making it round hundred yeah so just
like you'd go one side you can go the
other okay that's another ten
centimeters and they say of either P or
Q right so everything I've got over here
we're going to draw that yeah imma do
the same over here so there's ten right
and here's the last ten okay now do do I
want to be close to P and Q or do I want
to be far away find probably that the
point is within 10 centimeters so this
is the opposite of this question here I
want it to be outside now I want to be
inside close to pink you okay so
therefore the favorite outcomes right 10
20 30 40
there's 40 centimeters worth of a
favorable outcome okay now to finish off
the question I need to divide by the
sample space
what is 20 or 10 okay well what did they
start off saying a point is randomly
chosen from where 10 is that what the
question says
on the circumference anywhere on the
circumference yeah it up an account
that's fine up here over here they're
all fun alright so I gotta work out how
long this thing is I need to work out
what is the circumference already circle
okay now there are two formulas that
tell us about circumference and area
circumference in air and they look very
similar okay now there's these two
formulas right and they are very very
close to each other the question is
one's area wants to comforts which one
is which and how can you tell
Oh which one's area this one okay so
priestess and area might be like I don't
know til 10 square centimeters like
areas have to be spent because it's a
two-dimensional thing where is the
circumference it's just one arts it's
it's one dimension to link okay so good
therefore the circumference is 2pi ah
what's R the radius which is 1025
centimeters I guess okay that's the
sample space that's the same as base 20
okay now over here when I've gotten to
here I said could I simplify right and
the answer was no can I simplify here
yeah I can't so if I can support a lot
actually
what's the common factor I could take
out about what's the common factor in
the numerator could be go come on
20 you can find that by 20 you can
divide that by 20 right to the point
I mean why why is it high that's a great
question where did it come from it came
from the circumference the circumference
is got a plan so therefore our
probability will have a PI as well now
if you're interested you can't work out
what that is you can get a calculator
right and you can say what is 2 divided
by PI I don't know what is let's find
out 2 divided by PI and the decimal
you'll get is zero point six three six
six okay so be good they didn't tell you
you had to approximate sometimes they
will but so that means you know this
dance is fine but if you're curious
that's what the probability is
they'll they'll tell you they'll tell
you what to do okay they might say for
instance provide your answer to two
decimal places in which you would say
that's well can we write how does this
round off now you always but when you
think you're out rounding you think
about the digital chop and islands so if
I go to decimal place I'm gonna chop off
the six is six big or small it's big so
I'm gonna round up six four
alternatively they could say significant
figures and you know how to do that now
maybe I should have said one more thing
you know when we're talking about the
different attributes of these questions
have this is hard because you remember
we got two here right we wrote down the
favorable outcomes but then when you get
to sample space you're stuck what do we
have to do at this point
what we had to have this conference
didn't we
right so that's why this is this problem
it brings together it combines more than
one topic right you thought it was just
a probability question and it is a
problem to the question but then you
need to know stuff about circles and it
sticks them together all at once as you
look later on you'll have to do
probabilities and areas right and it's
the same kind of idea